Namo tassa bhagavato arahato samma-sambuddhassa Namo tassa bhagavato arahato samma-sambuddhassa Namo tassa bhagavato arahato samma-sambuddhassa
Homage to the blessed, noble and fully self-enlightened one.
So now, what I'm going to try and do is give you the full panoramic view of the Theravada process of enlightenment, the actual practice.
Not so much the theory, the theories behind it, but exactly what the practice is.
Interestingly enough, it's not based directly on the Buddha's teaching.
It so happened that a certain monk called Punnamantaniputta,
His name would be Punna, the son of Mantani, like Sariputta, called after your mother.
And he's been heard of as being a very good, he's understood the Dharma.
So Sariputta goes off to see him.
And they don't know each other, or rather Sariputta knows him, he doesn't know Sariputta.
And Sariputta puts him to these questions, you see, and asks him, what's his understanding of the Dharma?
And I'll read this simile first.
As to that friend, in other words, how does one attain nirvana?
I shall give you a simile, for some wise men understand the meaning of a statement by means of a simile.
Suppose that King Pasenadi of Kursala, while living in Sarvati, had some urgent business to settle in Sakata, and that between Sarvati and Sakata seven relay chariots were kept ready for him.
Then King Pasenadi of Kursala, leaving Sarvati through the inner palace door, would mount the first chariot, and by means of the first relay chariot he would arrive at the second relay chariot.
Then he would dismount from the first chariot and mount the second chariot.
And by means of the second chariot he would arrive at the third chariot.
By means of the third chariot he would arrive at the fourth.
Very exciting stuff.
Finally, of course, he does actually get to the seventh chariot.
And by means of the seventh chariot, he would arrive at the inner palace door of Saqqata.
Then, when he had come into the inner palace door, his friends and acquaintances, his kinsmen and relatives would ask him, Sire, did you come from Sabati to the inner palace door in Saqqata by means of this relay chariot?
How then should King Pashtunari of Kosala answer in order to answer correctly?
And it's told us again.
So now,
When he talks about these chariots, he talks about this.
Purification of virtue is for the sake of reaching purification of mind.
Purification of mind is for the sake of reaching purification of view.
Purification of view is for the sake of reaching purification of mind.
by overcoming doubt.
Purification by overcoming doubt is for the sake of reaching purification by knowledge and vision of what is the path and what is not the path.
Purification by knowledge and vision of what is the path and what is not the path is for the sake of reaching purification of knowledge and vision of the way.
Purification by knowledge and vision of the way is for the sake of reaching purification by knowledge and vision
Purification by knowledge and vision is for the sake of reaching final nirvana without clinging.
It is for the sake of final nirvana without clinging that the Holy One has lived under the Blessed One.
Need I explain?
So,
This particular system of explaining the Dhamma, the Buddha acknowledged it as being very good, was used most successfully by Buddhaghosa.
Well, first of all, it's Upatissa, which was 3rd century AD, or Common Era.
And his book is called The Path of Freedom.
It got lost and it only existed in the Chinese.
And as far as I know, it helped to revive Buddhism in Tibet through Asita, who found the book.
It was only recently translated from the Chinese back into English.
But who took that system and made it into what must be one of the great world classics of spiritual manual is Buddhaghosa.
That's his book.
The Path of Purification.
Very dense, full of all sorts of little exercises.
It's basically a manual on how to practice and all sorts of things.
And it's considered to be a handbook on Theravada Buddhism.
So whoever knows this book...
Basically, it understood Theravada Buddhism.
It's a pleasant weekend read.
So, if we look at, first of all, the purification of virtue, this word sila,
It's translated as morality, conduct, precepts, etc., etc.
But the Buddha calls the actual precepts, for want of a better word, the Sikarpada.
So it's the path, pada, of training.
This is the path of training.
And having established his four sanghas, laymen, laywomen, nuns, monks and that,
he gave a basic sealer, a basic conduct concerning what not to do.
So you all know them.
It's the five precepts.
And then if you want to strengthen it, you do the eight precepts, which these days is talked about as going for an agarica.
So you've got a lay sort of junior monastic.
Then you take the ten precepts, and at that point you would become an order member.
And then you take
this whole load of precepts, 227 of them, when you enter the order.
All these precepts, as far as I know, are all negatives, what you don't do.
And it's always starting from the position that our behavior, which is unskillful and unwholesome, is a measure of our delusion.
So if we can stop that behavior, if we can actually put an end to that sort of behavior, then it draws us into the middle, away from it, when it begins to take off as a virtue.
So if you look at something like the first precept, not to kill,
not to kill human beings, that's the most grossest thing, you see, but then you can refine that to not to harm any living being, not to harm any living being.
But of course, when you move to that position of not harming any living being, there's a movement towards compassion, isn't there?
See, it's the opposite, towards amity, love and all that, it shades one into the other.
If you think about the next one, which is not to take what is not freely given, so obviously a gross would be to rob a bank.
In its more finer thing, it's actually not to take anything which has not been given to you at all, so even a pen from work.
You can't take it because it's not been actually given to you for any other purpose than to be at work.
It's a sort of refinement.
The opposite, of course, what you move into is generosity, giving away.
And then of course you find that by being generous, you lose your desire for things.
Remember that stealing or taking something that's forbidden is just feeding that ego which feels this lack.
So by giving something, you actually undo the process of that lack within you by an act of generosity.
If you take that whole business around sexual behavior, I mean, as it's grossest, it's all sorts of horrible stuff, rape and all that.
Then as you get more and more refined, you get to the point of, say, for instance, just sex for sex is safe, which Woody Allen pointed out was an empty experience, but as empty experiences go, it was not right.
If it moves into a loving relationship, then of course it moves into something much more meaningful.
But the end refinement of that, very difficult for people to come to accept, is of course celibacy, because it's drawing out the energy or the desire to find happiness in sexual pleasure.
It draws out.
If you take wrong speech, so obviously on one side it's just real whoppers, you know, greatly lies.
And as you then stop exaggerating, to stop even an effort to exaggerate, to go beyond as far as you can see what the facts are, and then of course it becomes generous speech, truthful speech, kindly speech, because you're not trying to gain anything from it.
When it comes to the alcohol and all that sort of stuff, and it's grossest, of course, getting blind drunk or on drugs.
But as you become more and more refined, then you obviously feel that alcohol does have this effect on your consciousness, you see.
And interestingly enough, in one of the recensions, one of the classifications of the morality, only the first four are rated.
The last one's put in because it's under that influence that we actually do harm, you see.
But of course, you can take drugs and drinks and stuff like that which can actually harm the body.
So it's a refinement of that, you see, of caring for the body.
So then one moves into being very careful what you feed the body, what you put into the body.
So, on the one level, you have all these precepts, all worked out at these different levels, which are guiding us not to fall into error.
And then you have, for instance, all the parami, the perfections, which are telling us what to develop on the other side.
So the whole of our personality or psychology is being moved through the practice of these practices of sila, of conduct.
We're moving from something which is quite gross and an expression of our delusion towards something which is an expression of the Enlightenment.
So finally, you get to the Vinaya, the rule of the monks.
So what's the Buddha actually trying to do there?
Because it's all what you can't do.
There's nothing in the Vinaya which says what you can do, it just says what you can't do.
But interestingly enough, there's parts of the Vinaya which are to do with gross things, like not to steal, not to kill.
But when you come to the end, it becomes very refined.
Like, for instance, you're not supposed to chapu-chapu and suru-suru.
Chapu-chapu means to chop your food, and suru-suru means to slurp your drink.
We've got all these little rules, you see, and we're not supposed to talk.
If I talk to my neighbour here, I should be in a voice which the other neighbour doesn't hear.
Right?
So there's a sort of effort to point out that as we become more and more refined, everything becomes more and more refined.
The problem of course for the modern age is that many of these rules and regulations were to do with that particular society and time.
But when it comes to the refinement, then it does actually pass through time.
so now the big problem for people who are into developing that sort of purity the purity of sila, the purity of conduct is that they can get themselves into a double bind because the double bind is I cannot attain the enlightenment until the sila is perfected ok
But I can't have perfect sila until I'm enlightened.
It only comes with the Enlightenment.
So you'll often get people in the monastic orders especially who get themselves in this ridiculous double bind and they just end up worrying all the time.
Going to hell.
So the point of the matter is that these are just sort of guidelines.
They're given to us as guidelines as to what not to do and what to do.
So even if you look at the discourses concerning people...
Family life, you know, how the husband should treat the wife, the wife, the husband, and all that sort of stuff.
Even though it's dated, you can see that there was a contractual way of dealing with family members, which was to produce peace, harmony, and goodwill.
Okay.
So that's the basis.
Now when we go through these, it's not a case of that they come, first you do this, then you do that.
It's a continual motion.
So being aware of our ethical behavior, of our moral behavior, is the basic rule for spiritual advancement.
Every time we behave unskillfully, it's a measure of our delusion.
So you can't, you know, a lot of people might like to say, well, you know, I want to meditate, I want to get on with it, but I don't want to keep these rules.
They get in the way.
But in fact, you can't do that, because these rules that you break are measuring back to you your state of delusion.
Okay.
The next section is the purification of the mind.
Now this actually refers to the development of the jhana, absorptions.
So having now worked with trying to get rid of unskillful actions of speech and body, that's what sila is.
It doesn't matter what's going on in your head.
It's just that you don't throw it outward into the world in terms of something that you say or something that you do.
You then work inwardly through concentration exercises.
And concentration exercises can take you into these lovely jhanic states.
And what the meditator knows by that is that in order to get these beautiful states, ecstatic states, they don't actually need the world out there.
You can produce them within yourself just by repetition of a word or the use of an image or the use of an emotion like love, metta.
And you can go through these little stages of bliss and reach these lovely states of inner happiness and they're not dependent on what you've eaten or who's been talking to you.
And the danger, of course, is to find yourself in a little hut stuck somewhere up in a mountain and being absolutely blissed out.
But remember that the problem with Samatha, the problem with that sort of meditation, is that it always sits upon those parts of us in our hearts which have not been dealt with.
Now that can be extended.
That can be extended to the abhinya, the powers.
So you end up with things like the divine eye, the divine ear, which means that you can see through walls and hear things which other people can't hear.
You can read people's minds and all those sorts of things.
Right?
And that's the development of the mind which goes beyond the frame, the physical frame.
See, the physical frame.
you can see how in the development of sila conduct it can shade off and from what is unwholesome to wholesomeness and you move into compassion so you can see the extension of sila the extension of the parami the extension of perfection is the bodhisattva ideal which is what the Mahayana did with it
when it comes to the jhāna and the powers you can see the Tantra took that line and began to develop it and took the position that to be a fully fledged Buddha you had to be able to do this
So now, having developed these different powers of honor, which is not necessary, remember that there are two paths, the dve jnana, in Theravada they use the word jnana, you know, somebody remind me, jnana, what does it mean?
Vehicle, thank you.
The dve jnana and the ekka jnana.
So the dve jnana is to practice your concentration and your vipassana.
One developing against the other.
One of the great masters of that, if you read his books, is Ajahn Mahabua.
He has it in his manual on how to practice.
He practices the jhāna.
He goes for a rest in jhāna.
When he's ready, he goes back to vipassana.
When he's had enough of that, he goes back to jhāna, refreshes himself.
And in this way, you can sit for hours.
But the ekayāna, the direct path, if you're a fundamentalist, the only path, according to Jnana Ponika, Bhikkhu Bodhi, those of you who know, corrected him and put the direct path here.
Ekkayana means the one-way path, which is through just vipassana.
And that's really the path of the Mahasi.
The Mahasi system is just that one path, which is not at all concerned with trying to get blissed out or anything of that nature, but to develop vipassana to the bitter end.
Okay, so that's your second purification.
Now, at this point, we're ready to move, as it were, into the purifications of view, which is going to change our relationship to the world and bring about the libanic peace.
And the first thing is the purification of view, meaning here wrong view about the personality, about the body.
and you begin to separate the body from the mind.
So the first thing that in your meditation you begin to do is recognize that this is the body and this is the mind.
So for instance, the rising and falling of the abdomen is the body.
That which knows it, notes it, is the mind.
They're two different things.
You begin to separate these things out.
When you're eating, you note that the sensation on your tongue is the body
The heart with its response of joy is the mind.
This is beginning to, as it were, undo this wholesomeness, this whole, the idea that things are whole.
If you look at the canon, the Buddha's constantly trying to deconstruct what we think to be entire.
He does it by way of the five khandhas, the five heaps.
He does it by way of the six ayatanas, the six spheres, referring to the six senses.
He does it by way of the dhatus, right?
So he's constantly saying to us, look, if you look, you'll see everything's compounded.
But that looking has to be within ourselves through this careful investigation, this careful watching of what's happening inside us.
So that's actually a vipassana knowledge.
And that has to be more and more clarified as we meditate.
And that changes our relationship.
to the body and mind the next one is the condition it's called the purification of overcoming doubt and what it's referring to is the karma it's referring to how things are happening and especially the role of intention so
When I watch the abdomen rising and falling and I note rising and falling, this noting is dependent on the rising and falling of the abdomen.
It's very simple stuff, but it's just catching the fact that everything arises dependent on everything else.
So nothing has its own existence.
So that knowledge can be taken to its ultimate degree of full enlightenment.
But at this stage, it's just beginning to recognize this business of dependency.
So when we do our walking meditation, we say intending to walk.
We actually acknowledge that without the intention, you don't walk.
One is the mind, one is the body.
So they're all rising in this codependent way.
So by now the meditator is actually meditating.
From now on we're talking about insights, vipassana insights, to see things as they really are.
So the first one to do with conduct was basically how we live our lives.
The next one, which is not absolutely necessary for enlightenment, is how we develop the beautiful factors within our minds.
And then we begin to do this careful investigation, careful direct experience of the body and mind, and these are the sorts of insights we come up with.
Then we finally begin to really meditate and we begin to see the three characteristics, one of them or all of them, one after the other, it doesn't matter, you're just aware of one of the three characteristics.
So now this is mainly happening within your meditations.
As you begin to develop this, the concentration is growing and you're really able to contact the fact that within your view you really see things that are arising and passing away.
And such is the force of your concentration that it's actually the same as first jhana.
And at that point, the mind is still.
There's still thinking.
The first jhana, you can have some thinking around it, some ideas come up, but the attention of the meditator is always on the experience, on the sensations as they arise and pass away.
Remember that although I'm talking about the breath, it's anything which arises within the mind.
An emotion, a feeling, a thought.
It's just seen as arising and passing away.
Or how we create suffering by forming a relationship of wanting and not wanting.
Or we get this idea that it's not me, not mine, because we're looking at it.
Right?
Just to point that out, in the commentaries they make the distinction between these two jhanas.
One is called Lākana jhāna and the other one is called Aramana jhāna.
The Lākana jhāna is that concentration
which is achieved on a characteristic, a micha dukanata.
That's the concentration.
That's why it's known as kanika samadhi, momentary samadhi, meaning that it doesn't matter what arises and passes away within your consciousness, you're there with it.
The Aramana jhana is the concentration you get on an object, on a still object.
And that's why in jhana practice you always give the mind one object.
It could be just a feeling like may all beings be happy.
Or it could be one of these circles that you look at and then internalize.
It doesn't matter, it needs one object and the concentration grows around it.
Okay?
So, this idea of kanika samadhi, moment-to-moment concentration, is to do with the vipassana mind.
And the distinction between the vipassana mind and the samatha mind is that in the vipassana mind, there's intelligence.
You're actually making, there's a curiosity there, a wanting to know.
Okay?
Then,
Once that becomes clear, what happens is that delights arise which always come with good concentration.
And one begins to get what's known as the vipassana kilesa, the defilements of vipassana.
And there's about ten of them, just to give you some idea.
A light can appear in the mind.
A bright light.
Your head just brightens up.
Inside.
People might think they're enlightened.
Rapture, pity, great joy.
Happiness.
An enormous amount of energy arises.
You can meditate hours on end.
You don't have to go to sleep.
Equanimity.
You think you know it.
You think you've understood it.
You're about to write a book.
People get very deluded.
Tranquility.
Peace, lovely peace.
Determination, this enormous determination to get on with the job.
Enormous devotion.
All of these are actually healthy things.
They're all skillful.
What makes them unskillful is the last one, nikanti.
And nikanti is that indulgence.
And that's the mistake people make, because especially if they've never touched this sort of stuff before, and they experience these ecstatic states, they often mistake it for some real insight experience.
I know a friend of mine, he always talks about this, he was hardly at Amarwati, and he was actually on the toilet.
And this beautiful feeling came up.
And he was certain that he was enlightened.
Luther got his insight while he was on the toilet.
So, nisipasana kilesa, when the joy comes up, then you note them, exactly the same technique, you see what they are, etc., and you keep putting your attention, your curiosity, on the three characteristics, especially the rising and falling, especially anicca, everything's arising and passing away.
Then you hit what you might call the real insight, or something which shakes the mind.
And that is suddenly, there is this realization that everything comes to an end.
Banga Jnana.
And by that time, you're actually in the fourth jhana.
Your actual concentration has to be that sharp.
And that knowledge there is a cutting point.
Because now that's death.
It reverberates back on the mind, and your whole meditation collapses into what's known as the Dukkha Jnanas.
Now the Dukkha Jnana starts off first of all with a shaking of fear.
It's only a momentary thing.
But then there arises this feeling of disgust, a sort of horror to what's actually happening.
And eventually shades into a weariness.
And it's at this level that meditators suffer from enormous sloth, enormous talk or anger, all that sort of stuff.
Then as they go on, and they just keep meditating, you can get locked in these things, you see.
And remember that these things are also feeding into your psychology.
So part of it will be the spiritual insight of death, of the loss of self, and part of it will be because there's a load of sloth down there.
And it's bringing it up through this avenue.
And you keep going, you keep going, you just keep going.
And sloth and torpor are authentic, valid, perfectly wonderful states of mind to be observed and get curious about.
And then it shades into a desire to escape.
And that's this great restlessness that comes upon the meditator.
Often they start packing their bags and all that.
There was a lovely Carthusian monk who had meditated in Rangoon at the Mahasi Centre.
And he was very impressed by this.
He got his bags packed and he went to the teacher and he said, you know, he just couldn't handle it.
He just couldn't meditate, his mind was all over the place, absolutely a waste of time.
And the teacher said...
He'll have made it in 21 days.
On the 21st day, he made Sada Grana.
And just to finish that story off, he turned up a couple of months, a couple of years later to continue his training, and they said to him, you're a Buddhist now.
And he said, no.
And they were utterly confused by that.
And the fact is that these insights are not culture bound.
They're not even religion bound.
So that he would take that insight back into Christianity.
And re-translated in a Christian way.
And that's what he was doing, actually.
He was getting in trouble with his cardinal.
He died, unfortunately.
A lovely man.
So then, once we've got to that...
These contemplations of weariness and the desire for deliverance, they're all about special names.
There comes finally this reflection knowledge.
And at this point, this intelligence, this panna, centers on a particular characteristic, and it is seen at a depth not seen before.
And now this is used as the gateway to nirvana.
So if it sees anicca clearly, that's what it'll use to become enlightened.
If it sees dukkha, it'll use that if it sees anatta.
Now it's absolutely locked into that meditation.
And it moves into what's known as sankhara upeka.
Sankhara upeka is a state when the meditator simply cannot lose their awareness.
It just stays.
It is just so developed and so locked.
And there's an undeveloped part and a developed part.
In the undeveloped part, there's still some shaking.
And it's at this point that some trauma, some fundamental disturbance in the psyche is liberated.
To give you a sort of example of that, the very famous monk from Sri Lanka, a very old fellow, he died recently at the age of 101, somebody must know him.
Maitreya Ananda Maitreya so he came to Khandavoda which is my own monastery to practice in the Mahasi tradition and he came to this point and he suddenly had a memory of taking the Bodhisattva vow at the Buddha's time he remembered Sariputta's face and Moggallana's face but he couldn't remember the Buddha and he made this vow to become a Buddha so there's no way he could progress
Bodhisattva.
No, a self-enlightened Buddha.
That's what it means.
In Theravada, if you take the Bodhisattva vow, it means you vow to become a self-enlightened Buddha, which is different from the Mahayana.
So he had taken the vow to become a self-enlightened Buddha.
So from that point on, he couldn't move.
The rest of his life was developing his parami, he was developing his abilities.
And in the mythology, he will keep doing that until all the paramis are ready, he will be reborn into a particular place, a particular time, and within that life, go through the four stages of sanctity.
So that's the state of your sankara upeka, right?
And then the mind is on, and then it's put in this sort of way, there's a change of lineage, meaning that there's a shift in the level of consciousness.
Now what do we mean by that?
The best example that we've all been through is between the ages of six and eight.
Between six and eight, two things, many things happen, but two things in particular.
The first is a reality test.
At the age of six, Father Christmas can come down the chimney.
It's not a problem, is it?
At the age of eight, it's ridiculous.
so at the age of 6 what I imagine is just as real as what I experience out there at the age of 8 the distinction is made and you can't go back on that relationship to the world anymore the second thing that happens is even though young children do feel shame do feel guilt and all that at the age of 7 it becomes something concretised it becomes an actual complex within the mind about what's bad and what's good and again you cannot go back
You've shifted.
So at this point there's a shift in consciousness.
And then it takes its object as one of these characteristics.
And it sees it at such a deep level that that shift in the level of consciousness has been changed for good.
That's it.
And that's why it's called stream entrant.
You're entering into the stream of nobility.
The Sotapanna.
And at that point, after that, there is a momentary experience of nirvana.
And then there's a coming back.
The experience of that changes the view that this body, mind and heart, this personality, is the self.
But it only changes the view.
it doesn't change the relationship so the Sotapanna still acts and still believes at a certain level that they are the body the mind and the heart but they've seen it and the Buddha talks of it like a flash of lightning hmm
Now, to get to the next stage, it's the very same process.
It just deepens, it just deepens.
Some people, it's said, get there just by seeing transience all the way.
Some people by just seeing suffering, some people by just seeing not-self.
Others by seeing the three, quite separately in each stage.
So the other fetter that goes when you enter the stream is, of course, you lose doubt, because now you've seen the top of the mountain.
There's not a problem anymore.
So there's no doubt within the Sotapanna.
In terms of the Buddhist society, in terms of the Buddhist community, this is enormously important.
It is said that if there comes a time when there is not a Sotapanna within the Buddhist community, the religion will shade away into useless rituals.
and all this other stuff, because that vision has been lost in a community level, at a community level.
See?
So one goes through the same process, and what is undermined this time is your dependency on the world for happiness.
It's undermined, it's not got rid of.
And your anger, your aversion is undermined.
The Buddha talks about it, seeing things in a full starlit night.
The third one, the anagami, the non-returner, he says it's like seeing things as they really are in the full moon.
In the topical full moon you can see colour.
And it's only when we become fully enlightened that you can see things like the midday sun.
But the process is the same.
This continuous effort to see these three characteristics and just the deepening of that effort until consciousness is utterly liberated from trying to seek happiness in the phenomenal world.
So there's a whole total new relationship going on to the whole process.
And as that process goes, everything is being refined and being extended and being developed.
And it's up to the person to develop what they want.
So it may be that all our behavior is becoming more and more refined, more and more gentle, etc.
And we decide to develop compassion.
It may be that instead you decide to develop your intellect.
It may be that you decide to develop your powers.
So when Moggallana asks Sariputta, how is it he's not developed the powers?
He has this enormous understanding, second only to the Buddha.
Why hasn't he developed the powers like Moggallana?
He says, I'm not interested.
So even enlightened beings can be quite different.
They don't turn out to be clones of
And just to give you another image that the Buddha gives in terms of the path, he talks about people swimming underwater.
They're the deluded ones.
And he talks about people swimming and their heads bob up every so often.
So they're the trainees.
And then there's the ones who tread water.
Their heads always bob up.
Then there's the ones who swim towards the shore.
They're the anaganis, they're the once-returner.
And when you stand on the shore, you're finally on the island, then you're a non-returner.
You've left at least this gross, sensual world.
And you make your way to the centre of the island, and then you become a fully-fledged arahant.
These images are very telling of the practice.
The effort to get from underwater to be treading water is enormous.
But once you get there, you can tread water.
You can stay there for a very long time.
The effort to get from treading water to the island is a real effort.
Once you're on the island, it's no big deal getting to become enlightened.
They're actually very valid sort of images that he uses.
He's not just giving us little images for the sake of it.
So, just finally, to link it in with the three characteristics that we've been discussing, it says, you see, whosoever being filled with determination, right, through the practice, considers all formations as impermanent, such a one attains the conditionless liberation.
So they experience the liberation as being unconditioned.
Whosoever being filled with tranquility considers the formations as unsatisfactory, dukkha, such a one attains the desireless liberation.
For them, that experience of liberation is no desire, no attachment.
Whosoever being filled with intuitive intelligence considers all formations as not-self, such a one attains the emptiness liberation, the sunyata.
They experience it as empty of self.
So, I think that brings me to an end of my explication.
So, just to recap for you, these seven chariots
were a concoction of Punya Mantani Buddha, his monk.
And the Buddha said it was okay, it'll do.
It was picked up by Upatissa, who is considered to be an Arahant, who is considered to be enlightened.
It's a very different book from Buddhaghosa's.
And Buddhaghosa took the same form to write his manual that we can read.
And this is a very scholastic effort.
You don't get the feeling that Buddha Gosu is an arahat.
You get the feeling he's very clever.
And then these seven factors are the purification of view, sorry, the purification of conduct, the purification of conduct by way of not doing what is skillful and developing what is skillful,
The purification of the mind, meaning through the jhana, to build up those beautiful states, which remember is not necessary for the enlightenment.
And then we begin the insight knowledges.
The separation of body from mind, their connection,
And then you go through the real vipassana jhanas, which is to see the three characteristics, to see dissolution, and then to go through the suffering of what is actually the suffering of death, the loss of self.
The depression and all that sort of stuff, the running away.
Suddenly there's an insight which directs you towards the goal, the equanimity, and then the reaching of the goal, the release of that consciousness from its fetters, which has been causing it trouble, and...
an establishment of a certain level of consciousness, which is a way of relating to the world, not to be confused with a state of mind, which is an emotion or a thought.
It's the way we relate to the world, the way we are in the world, which is what is changing through the practice of Vipassana.
So, if you really want to know about that, in much more detail, I've written, I've given you some books.
I think the ones that I'd like you to add on is The Heart of Buddhist Meditation by Jnana Ponica.
It's still, I think it's still the classic.
The Heart of Buddhist Meditation.
The Handbook on Mental Training Based on the Buddha's Way of Mindfulness.
A Heart of Buddhist Meditation by Jnana Ponika.
N-Y-A-N-A-P-O-N-I-K-A.
Jnana Ponika.
And another minor classic, absolutely wonderful little book, Insight Meditation by Joseph Goldstein.
These are just little essays, and it is based on the Mahasi technique, but it's a lovely little book.
And it's something you can use on a personal retreat and just read occasional chapter.
It's a lovely little book.
the one for the stages of insight are the ones I've given you there on that piece of paper by Nyanarama the seven stages yeah also the Mahasi has written one called progress and insight I've written that down for you
He's got his practical vipassana exercises.
The seven contemplations of insight are just a greater explication of the three characteristics.
This is definitely a classic in this very life by Upandita.
And that's where he explains these vipassana jhanas which confuse so many people.
That'll keep you going.
Really, and the last is a caveat, is a warning.
This is, I think, to my knowledge, I think I've done it twice before actually, this is the only time that I've actually taught this stuff.
And the reason is very simple.
It's so easy to get a conceptual idea of what the path is, and then you start striving for it.
And you really, really have to tell yourself that this is completely beyond your control.
Completely.
You cannot make any of these insights happen.
And if you try, then that's the ego getting in the way.
You see?
That's the ego getting in the way.
So my advice to you is to sort of read them and just, as it were, know they're there because they're part of faith.
I mean, this is a well-worn path.
People experience it.
It's there to be had.
And then just to forget them.
It's about the faith.
Well, it's to point out, you see, people don't realize how delineated the path is.
They think it's some sort of hazy thing.
But it's very clearly delineated.
And by the way, this isn't the only way you can become enlightened.
This is the Theravada way through the practice of Vipassana.
It's very, you know...
It's possible.
Forget time.
I've known people to struggle for five years.
I've known people to do it in six weeks.
I've known people still at it.
So forget time.
It doesn't work like that.
It doesn't work at all.
But knowing this and within that sort of system, then you know, you just keep working and things arise.
In this life or the next or the next.
So I think that's my little bit.
Really, it's just questions.
Yeah.
Well, I think that what he was establishing through the monastic path was a way, was an institution for that sort of commitment.
If you really wanted to become enlightened, if you really did, you'd drop everything right now.
well in any in any any path you want to choose if you really want it you'll go for it
Can't you become enlightened without one of those paths?
I don't know of any process of enlightenment which doesn't have a path to it, because it's a progress.
It's not as though you're an enlightenment and suddenly you're enlightened.
It's a development, there's a progress to it.
Yeah, I just meant without...
I think it's a very valid question.
Say somebody just living on their own in the middle of nature.
This is just an example.
It could be anything.
Living on their own in the middle of nature.
Just living their life.
I mean, without a program like you've set out like that, could they not in their own way
achieve some degree of whatever it might be like?
I don't know.
I wouldn't do it.
I don't sense that the woman is held back by the wife.
I mean, I don't know.
Just being honest, I felt.
It can be a little dull.
I didn't do it when I was there.
But just the thought came up to me, Christianity.
And I mean, his approach and his teaching seems to be
very much about not following a path.
Well, two things there.
You're presuming he was enlightened.
That's number one.
And number two, even though he said meditation was useless and shouldn't follow a path, if you read his writings, it's full of a path.
If there's a book on elements, element publication, by somebody who's written a book on Krishnamurti's teaching, it's definitely a path.
I think there's a lot of contradictions there, but I think that's probably part of growing up into a way to investigate all of this in the West.
I think that's part of it, but he seemed to offer, or suggested, whether he was enlightened or not.
I think...
I think that some Buddhist teachers... Yeah, I think...
He just seemed to offer kind of alternative ways
Well, you'd have to be... Yeah, that's it, you see.
You'd have to make a... You'd have to...
When you follow a path, you've got to make up your mind which path you're on.
If you're a Krishnamurti, then get over there and do it.
If you're on the Buddha's path, stay with the Buddha.
It doesn't work.
It doesn't work shifting...
I know that you feel this.
I know that you feel what you just said.
I do.
I don't feel it, is it?
It's a fact.
You say, I don't know.
I mean, practice perhaps.
I can really see the argument for committing to the practice at some point.
Well, it's up to you.
It's up to you, you see.
I mean, to me, the great image of the spiritual path is climbing a mountain.
If you want to go across the mountain to join another path, fine.
But then you're going to have to learn new techniques because it's a different path.
If you stay on the one path and you're quite certain it's going to the top, then you stay with it.
I think that's what I meant.
Do you have to... Do you have to follow a path?
Can you just line the path?
Does everybody have to ask a
Well, you know, a technique is simply a trick to get that consciousness into a particular position so it can watch.
That's all a technique is.
So if your technique is to hit yourself on the head with a mallet every so often to come back into the present moment, fine, that'll do.
It doesn't matter.
There are as many techniques as there are teachers.
The Mahasi technique really caught hold of the imagination, A, because of the clarity of his teaching.
It's always clarity that draws people.
Secondly, because at the time there was a real dearth of Vipassana meditation.
It was quite new.
The other person who came along was U Ba Khin, with the thing you did this afternoon with Christina.
And there was a void there of vipassana teaching.
And he had such a clarity about it.
But more than that, he's one of these people who could get people to work.
I mean, you hear this tape, four hours sleep.
This isn't easy.
That's the thing you've got to get across to yourself.
It's not easy.
You can't lie in the bath in the middle of nature and listen to the birds and become enlightened.
At least, very difficult.
Why?
Because this consciousness is forever seeking happiness in the phenomenal world.
That's the fundamental delusion about Dukkha.
It's always seeking comfort in the phenomenal world.
Therefore, the path necessarily is uncomfortable.
If you go to a monastery and feel comfortable, nothing's happening.
Nothing's happening.
If you're meditating and you've spent a week and all you can say is, it was absolutely beautiful, I was blissed out, I was fine.
When you come off a big pastoral retreat, the question is, what have I come to know?
What have I come to know?
What have I understood?
I don't want you to look so glum, Anneliese.
I'm not.
I've still got great questions for myself.
So, Billy Darwin, I have a question here that we wrote down.
We were talking earlier and we wanted to know what understanding of awareness, do you believe that awareness and consciousness are the same?
Is that a question to me?
Awareness and consciousness?
Yeah, it's tradition, because Christina was saying that everyone, lots of slightly different traditions, view this very differently.
I think most of the confusion is around words.
And most of the confusion arises about what Nibbāna actually is.
And if you look at the different schools, it splits into two.
Even in Theravada you'll get the same split, like the people in northern Thailand, under Ajahn Mun, who Ajahn Chah was a sort of disciple.
We'll talk about the Buddha.
They'll talk about a level of consciousness.
And you can point directly to the scripture and quote the Buddha.
There is a non-manifestive consciousness, a consciousness without object.
Without boundary and in all directions full of light.
So you get those schools that tell you that the enlightenment is an actual living, live consciousness, which when it descends into the world of phenomena, in other words, being human beings, has a very different relationship to that world to the person who is not enlightened.
Then you get the other school who think it's Nirodha Samapati.
Now Nirodha Samapati is Sanya Vedana Nirodha Samapati.
It's a state of, for want of a better word, unconsciousness, where all the ending of feeling and perception has gone.
And it can only be got through the jhana.
And it's only meant to be available to those people who are non-returners and the fully enlightened.
and you'll get a whole load of people that tell you that Nibbāna is that state of nirodha.
And it's difficult because the Buddha says
When you have sensual pleasure, people think this is the highest happiness.
But then they experience first jhāna, and they know that this sensual pleasure was quite low.
First jhāna is the highest happiness.
And then this way he takes you all the way up to the jhānas, and then he says, and when you come to the fourth jhāna, you flip into this nirodha samāpati.
This is the highest happiness.
So you're going to always have that argumentation in Buddhist schools as to what the actual end is, because for some reason the Buddha wasn't particularly clear on this one.
He didn't make a complete statement, we can say.
And to my mind, and the way it works for me is very simple.
What you see in the universe, is it not, is a constant clicking off and on, isn't it?
sleep and awakeness, winter and summer.
Even moments are arising and passing away, arising and passing away.
So for me, that consciousness can, as it were, step out of, into itself, in which case it does not experience itself as being in the phenomenal world.
And it can also experience itself within the phenomenal world, awake.
This on-off, on-off, rising-falling seems to be the fundamental movement within the whole of the universe, both at the phenomenal level and the spiritual level.
So the battle is always between death and birth, and death and birth.
And this suffering arises because this consciousness has simply identified with the phenomenal world of feeling, sensation, etc.,
So it depends on which school you want to belong to, where you want to go.
But for me, in a sense, that's all sort of endgame.
When we bring the practice right down to the present moment, then it's quite simple, quite straightforward.
What about awareness?
You spoke about consciousness and different ideas about consciousness.
This is just a question of definition.
It's a question of words.
you see even the Buddha uses vijnana as one of the khandhas and then he goes and uses it to express this consciousness which isn't a khandha it isn't one of the five aggregates he talks about citta and it's translated as the mind and we normally translate it as the heart mind what the old word soul used to refer to or I should say what the soul used to refer to and
citta and yet in his victory verse he says he's achieved the citta the unconditioned citta the unconditioned mind that can't be can't be emotions and thoughts and one of the kernel questions that somebody asked Sariputta is how is it Nibbana is blissful if there's no emotions he says there's very absence of emotions which is the bliss of Nibbana
Now if that seems horrible to you, that's a measure back to us of how we rate our happiness according to our emotions.
So I trust you're all sort of confused.